mittlerweile ist die völker nein so weit
optimiert dass es zack auf zack gehen
könnte landen auftanken und innerhalb
von 24 stunden wieder abheben
die kosten für den raketenstart sollen
zeitnah noch weiter gesenkt werden
damit rückt mass version visionen immer
näher die besiedlung anderer planeten
was kann die neue version der folgen
einer rakete möglich und hat spacex
damit tatsächlich eine zeitenwende im
weltraum eingeleitet danke für diesen
hammer themenvorschlag von euch bei den
messengern und herzlich willkommen bei
pixum science fiction und den iren mass
chroniken
kurz noch mal in eigener sache die abo
box ist ja für viele youtuber ein graus
und sie würden immer größer ihr habt
einfach keine möglichkeit
sicherzustellen dass ihr erfahrt wenn
ein neues video online geht und das gilt
auch in abgeschwächter form für die
glocke deshalb meine bitte an mich und
vor allem in eurem interesse folgt mehr
auf whatsapp oder den anderen messengern
nur da verpasst ja garantiert kein video
mehr
ja wir reden hier immer wieder über
ihren maske und seinen
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex eines seiner
größten eine seiner größten schöpfung
ist wohl die falcon 9 rakete ja sowohl
der amazon chef bezos als auch in de
mars wollen die kolonisierung des
sonnensystems ermöglichen massen big
felken rocket die bfa so etwa in vier
jahren zum ersten mal bemannte raumflüge
im inneren sonnensystem möglich machen
beide männer kann man tatsächlich als
pioniere bezeichnen denn sie arbeiten
daran verkehrsmittel zu konzipieren die
eines tages massen an menschen in den
weltraum befördern könnten im mai dieses
jahres erfolgte dazu der nächste schritt
mit der falken ein block von spacex war
zum ersten mal überhaupt eine rakete
gestartet die ohne aufwändige
instandsetzung erneut abheben konnte und
noch vor ihrem start hatte elenas keinen
preis für die rakete der den preis für
die rakete von 62 millionen us dollar
auf 50 millionen gesenkt der volle preis
ist nur von denen noch zu zahlen die
eine komplett neue felgen einbestellen
ja und langfristig planas die kosten
immer weiter zu senken bis der preis
irgendwann bei 5 millionen dollar pro
start league möglich wäre das wenn die
meisten bestandteile der rakete wieder
verwendet werden werden und diese diese
angepeilte preis ist echt wow
denn der preis einer vergleichbaren
ariane-5 von arianespace als europa
dafür müssen interessenten etwa 180
millionen us dollar hinlegen
wirtschaftlich gesehen klingt das auf
den ersten blick vielleicht choreo form
sollte mast alle anderen konkurrenten
noch weiter unterbieten wenn er doch eh
schon mit abstand den besten preis
anbietet aber wie eben schon gesagt was
langfristige pläne sind es menschen ins
all zu bringen und das in etwa so
alltäglich zu machen wie wenn wir uns
heutzutage mit aller
selbstverständlichkeit ein taxi rufen um
von a nach b zu kommen er ist von seiner
sache fest
folgt damit die menschheit den dritten
weltkrieg überleben kann muss es möglich
sein auf anderen planeten zu siedeln
oder stephen hawking meinte ja um die
klimakatastrophe zu überleben eine reise
zum mars soll mass vision zufolge schon
in wenigen jahren erschwinglich sein
artikel soll demnach 100.000 us dollar
kosten ja alles fing im juni vor acht
jahren an 2010 damals war die erste
völkern eine rakete gestartet seitdem
wurde sie immer weiter optimiert jetzt
hat die rakete fast die doppelte masse
und kann zudem mehr als die doppelte
nutzlast transportieren der große punkt
die raketen sind ja wieder verwendbar
und zwar ziemlich komplett die felgen
ein block 5 ist laut basics die
endgültige version der rakete bis dann
etwa 2020 die bfa folgen soll im mai war
die völker neuen indien arbeit gestartet
und hatte den ersten satelliten april
liefert der für bangladesch gestartet
war das ziel ist eine flugpause von nur
24 stunden in diesem zeitraum soll
aufgetankt werden und die nutzlast
befestigt werden eine generalüberholung
gibt es erst nach ungefähr zehn flügen
das heißt jetzt wurden alle bauteile so
optimiert dass das zum ersten mal in der
geschichte der raumfahrt möglich ist zu
den größten veränderungen an der rakete
gehören beispielsweise das verschraubte
ob diese struktur an der die neuen
triebwerke befestigt werden wird bei
dieser neuen version nicht mehr
verschweißt so fällt eine aufwändige
inspektion der schweißnähte weg und neu
konstruiert zudem ist der hitzeschild am
rand der unteren stufe er muss jetzt
nicht mehr lackiert werden wertvolle
zeit wird also gespart preiswerte
raketen braucht ihnen was aber noch aus
einem anderen grund denn bis ins jahr
2027 will er mehr als 4400 satelliten in
flache umlaufbahn bringen
langfristiges ziel sind weitere 7000 die
dann alle einen superschnellen
internetzugang weltweit ermöglichen
sollen zehn milliarden us dollar werden
für die platzierung der satelliten
kalkuliert weitere kosten für wartung
sind da noch nicht eingerechnet und
genau das ist mass zweites motiv für
seinen plan preiswerte staat kosten für
raketen möglich zu machen um das nächste
riesengeschäft zu starten viele andere
unternehmer sind an solchen mammut
projekten gescheitert
was bisher noch nicht wenn er kein video
zu ihrem us raketenpläne
zu allen anderen dem verpassen wollt
dann endet mich bei whatsapp und den
anderen messenger nur dann verpasst er
kein video die abo box auf youtube user
immer ziemlich lückenhaft über die
messenger erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video täglich
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
zur begrüßung habe ich ein kleines
goodie und am besten auch mein
schwesterkanal klicks um social media
abonnieren da erfahrt ihr das neueste
aus der social media welt aktuell die
anhörung von mark zuckerberg vor dem
europäischen parlament dafür hier
klicken und nicht die glocke vergessen
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken dem start der falcon heavy
live hier auf dich zum ja das war der
absolute wahnsinn
wer es noch nicht gesehen hat ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran